Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
These amazing images were all made by an AI
called DALL-E 2. This AI is endowed with a
diffusion-based model, which means that when
we ask it something, it starts out from noise,
and over time, it iteratively refines this image
to match our description better. And, over time,
magically, an absolutely incredible image emerges.
This is a neural network that is given a ton of
images, and a piece of text that says what is
in this image. That is one image-caption pair.
DALL-E 2 is given millions and millions of these
pairs. So, what can it do with all this knowledge?
The key takeaway here is that it does no, or
very little copying from this training data, but
it truly comes up with novel images. How? Well,
after it had seen a bunch of images of koalas,
and separately, a bunch of images of motorcycles,
it starts to understand the concept of both,
and it will be able to combine the two
together into a completely new image.
And luckily, due to the generosity of OpenAI,
I also have access and I tried
my best to push it to its limits.
It can also generate an image of you
Fellow Scholars marveling at this paper,
or in the process of reading an even
more explosive paper. So good! I also
tried this fox scientist in an earlier
episode, and it came out extremely well
with tons of personality. And, hold on to
your papers because due to popular request,
you are getting some more variants from
my experiment with it. And DALL-E 2 did
not disappoint. This character can
be recreated as a beautiful sculpture
with several amazing variants, Dragonball
style, and it is also a true merch monster.
But, we also tested it against the works of real
artists. My opinion is that it is not yet as good
as a world-class artist, here are some tests
against Judit Somogyvári’s work, and it is also
not as good as the king of donuts, Andrew Price,
however, DALL-E 2 is able to create 10,000 images
every day. That is a different kind of value
proposition. So, we ask today, after these amazing
results, does it really have more surprises up
the sleeve? Oh boy. By the end of this video,
you will see how much of a silly question that
is. So today, we are going to have a look at
10 recent amazing results, some of which are from
prompts that I ran for you on Twitter. Let’s see!
For instance, one this is from you.
Schrödinger's cat gripping the latest
research papers. Loving the glasses and
the scholarly setting, and, wait a minute.
Don’t eat them! Come on! What results are
you trying to hide? We will never know.
Two, this is a screaming tiger
trading cryptocurrencies. And,
yes, you are seeing correctly, the meme game is
strong here. The resemblance is uncanny! So good!
Three, I am always curious about what it
thinks about itself. Well, let’s ask it
to make a self-portrait of itself looking in
the mirror. It identifies as a robot. Okay,
got it, that makes sense. And it is also… a
penguin? Excuse me? And a robotic frog too
that seems surprised by its own existence.
How cool is this? Also, food for thought.
Four, it can create battle maps
for tabletop roleplaying games.
And I bet variants of these will
also inspire some of you Fellow
Scholars to dream up amazing new
board games or even video games.
Five, we can’t have enough cats, can we? This
is one falling into a black hole. I love how
expressive the eyes are. The first two seem quite
frightened about this journey. First time? But the
third one, this chap seems really confident. And,
I love how it also inspired you Fellow Scholars
with these memes that are now starting to appear
on these DALL-E 2 images. Keep the game going!
Six, I now introduce you, to the king of
life. A dabbing walrus with sunglasses.
This one here is an excellent testament to the
creative capabilities of DALL-E 2. Clearly,
its training set did not contain
images of walruses in sunglasses,
and much less ones that are dabbing. It made this
thing up on the spot. What a time to be alive!
Seven, if you think that
this world is a simulation,
and you wish to see what it looks like from
the outside, DALL-E 2 has you covered. Oh yes!
Now, eight. let’s put it to the real test with
Noam Chomsky’s classic sentence. Colorless green
ideas sleep furiously. He put this together
to show that you can create a sentence that
is grammatically correct, but semantically, it is
complete nonsense. No meaning whatsoever. Well,
DALL-E 2 begs to differ. Here are its
ideas. This idea seems is colorless,
with a bit of green paint from the bed,
and it seems that it was asleep and it is
now furious. This one makes me feel that the AI
can create anything. A true creativity machine.
Nine, anything you say? Well, this one is
from the amazing DALL-E 2 subreddit. And
it showcases Bob Ross painting
himself in infinite recursion.
This is one of the most impressive
prompts I have seen yet. Wow.
Ten, I really wanted to make a squirrel with a
malfunctioning laptop. I tried to push DALL-E 2 to
the limits in creating this with a huge variety
of different styles and to say that I was not
disappointed would be an understatement. Look
at these beautiful results! My goodness! It can
do Disney style, cartoon style, oil paintings,
I feel like this can do absolutely anything.
And, +1 because I can never resist. This is Kermit
the frog in fight club. Oh yes. It seems to me
that he went for the method actor route and made
the role his own. Better not mess with this guy.
And, you know what, if you have been holding on to
your papers so far, now, squeeze your papers, for
+2. I hear you asking, Károly, why are you posting
the thumbnail of an earlier Two Minute Papers
video here? What is this? Is it possible that…oh
yes. M-hmm! That is exactly right. Quite a few of
our last thumbnails were made by DALL-E 2. What
a time to be alive! My wonderful wife, Felícia
Zsolnai-Fehér does the rest of the design work on
these gorgeous thumbnails. I absolutely love them.
She is so good. Not only in graphic design, but
her pencil drawing was also compared to DALL-E 2,
and she was one of the amazing artists who was
able to beat DALL-E 2. At least, in my opinion.
So, as you see, DALL-E 2 is transforming the world
around us. And fast. Just a couple years ago,
I was wondering whether we could
take an AI, just say what we want,
and get a high-quality thumbnail
for our videos, and I thought,
well, maybe in my lifetime. By the time I become
an old man, perhaps such a thing would exist. And,
boom, just a couple more papers down the line,
and here we are. I truly cannot believe how good
these results are. What a time to be alive! And
don’t forget, this was what DALL-E 1 was capable
of just a bit more than a year ago, and now,
one more paper down the line, and the results
are outstanding. I wonder what DALL-E 3 will be
capable of? I bet it is already in the works. So,
does this get your mind going? Which work did
you like best? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!